zone europe avec le soutien du fonds
citoyen franco allemand
[Musique]
tieger
et toi
charlie bell
c'est parfait
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans zone europe /
radio sensations et tv 78 une émission
spéciale réalisée avec le fonds citoyen
franco allemand à l'occasion de la
journée franco allemande du 22 janvier
nous vous emmenons à aschaffenburg en
allemagne cette ville se trouve en
bavière elle est jumelée avec la ville
de saint germain en laye dans les
yvelines les jumelages il en sera bien
sûr question dans cette émission mais on
s'intéressera aussi à l'amitié franco
allemande aux échanges culturels aux
mobilités et à l'environnement à travers
des initiatives dont on pourrait
peut-être s'inspirer en france mais sans
plus tarder on part à la découverte de
la ville parfois surnommé l'anis
bavarois suivez le guide il s'appelle
parfait
ce lieu est intéressant parce que d'ici
on a un panorama sur à peu près mille
ans d histoire d'aschaffenburg
le château lui-même représente ici à peu
près 800 ans
de règne d
des archevêques prince électeur de
mayence s'est achevée avec prince
électeur de mayence
étaient
des gens très puissants dans l'enceinte
dans le saint-empire romain germanique
comme on l'appelait à l'époque et cet
empire romain germanique
il était très puissant parce que
les ils étaient les premiers chancelier
de du collège électoral il était dans le
collège électoral avait une voix
prépondérante dans l'accord le collège
électoral et certains d'entre eux qui
étaient encore les plus puissants et est
de surcroît cardinaux et les cardinaux
elysées d'un côté l'empereur et de
l'autre côté le pape alors élisant donc
les deux personnalités les plus
puissantes de la terre à cette époque là
ça leur donnait aussi une grande
puissance donc il était souvent très
courtisé parmi les plus célèbres on à
albrecht von brandenburg et albrecht von
braun burqa était un des plus puissants
et c'est aussi celui qui était
cardinal prince électeur de mayence du
temps où il ya eu le schisme de l'église
sur de l'église
zone europe / sensations
où
aschaffenburg ville jumelée avec saint
germain en laye dans les yvelines
l'importance des jumelages et des liens
franco-allemands on écoute tout de suite
ce qu'en pense jorgen erding c'est le
maire de la chapelle gourdes
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
il était nécessaire que les gens se
retrouvent de nouveau
d'abord l'amitié a été fixé sur le
papier les personnes officiels se sont
mis en contact
le maire de saint germain et le maire de
aschaffenburg
la france l'allemagne ensuite il est
très important que les gens se
retrouvent les élèves les associations
pour entretenir l'amitié et pour
communiquer entre eux
je suis à présent avec hélène chrétien
bonjour alors vous occuper notamment du
jumelage entre les villes
d'aschaffenburg saint germain en laye
qui a été scellé en 1975 alors déjà pour
commencer en quoi ces deux villes se
ressemblent et pourquoi est ce que c'est
important les jumelages et ces deux
villes se ressemblent d'abord parce
qu'elles ont une taille à peu près
similaire aschaffenburg est un peu plus
grande que saint germain mais saint
germain s'est agrandie
avec
en associant des communes voisines donc
finalement je pense que maintenant on
est à peu près à des villes de taille
vraiment très proches
saint germain c'est une ville proche du
nôtre très grandes villes paris et une
autre échelle bien sûr c'est un achat
fanbook c'est un peu la même chose donc
c'est proche de francfort et donc il ya
aussi beaucoup de d'habitants de la
ville ici qui vont travailler travailler
à à francfort et donc ils font la
navette tous les jours et donc en quoi
les les jumelages c'est important
je pense que
c'est important parce que ça permet aux
habitants de lier des relations amicales
avec d'autres personnes et qu'une fois
qu'on est lié d'amitié avec des
personnes de cultures différentes
eh bien on regarde
le pays étrangers autrement et l'europe
de manière générale aussi autrement
alors pour créer ces liens il existe
différents différents programmes
justement en dehors de la période de
crise sanitaire qu'on connaît
actuellement quels sont les échanges et
activités qui sont programmés au fur et
à mesure de l'année entre les deux
villes alors les échanges ils se font
aussi bien au niveau de la jeunesse avec
les écoles dont il ya plusieurs lycées
de saint germain qui sont associés à des
lycées d'aschaffenburg ou des collèges
aux dépens des classes
et puis il ya des associations sportives
qui se rencontrent régulièrement
par exemple il ya un groupe de cyclistes
de saint germain et un autre
d'aschaffenburg qui organise dès
lors des déplacements on voit là des
grands déplacements entre les deux
villes un vélo donc par étapes un peu
comme le tour de france mais là c'est
pain tout comme paris 6 mai par yahia
fond voilà c'est ça et là je pense que
c'est vraiment une bonne occasion pour
les cyclistes d'apprendre sur plusieurs
jours à se connaître
et puis il ya des associations plus axé
sur la culture qui qui font des choses
ensemble
par exemple des chorales donc et une
chorale d'aschaffenburg très réputé qui
par exemple s'est produite avec une
chorale de saint germain saint germain
et aschaffenburg donc ils se sont
rencontrés deux fois pour qu'un
spectacle en commun voilà il ya des
spectacles en commun donc ça c'est aussi
très intéressant et ses projets ça
permet aussi à des gens qui ne parlent
pas la langue de l'autre de faire quand
même quelque chose ensemble parce que
souvent on dit oui mais pour les
allemands le français c'est pas évident
pour les français c'est pas évident non
plus reste l'anglais langue connue
commune mais en fait finalement la
musique c'est aussi une langue et le
sport quelque part aussi après je pense
qu'il n'y a plus besoin de beaucoup de
mots pour pour apprendre à se à se
comprendre et à se connaître et à
s'apprécier et l'amitié franco-allemande
vous la caractérise et comment
c'est très dur et
je pense que c'est positif
mais que sait on
c'est positif
mais en même temps si on discute avec
certaines personnes on sent qu'il ya
encore les clichés qui sont là des idées
un peu préconçues qui sont pas toujours
positives
vous disiez tout à l'heure il ya de
nombreux projets qui sont mis en place
notamment justement sur internet c'est
le cas du projet et demain verville der
kahn qui a été mis en place avec des
jeunes de saint germain en laye et
d'aschaffenburg qui y ont participé
l'occasion de réfléchir à l'après crise
sanitaire et à la ville de demain en
faisant une grande place à
l'environnement on les écoute tout de
suite à 2000 myriam brest
1-1 fox
pouvez vous nous expliquer le but du
projet et demain vers ville d'arkham
l'objectif de notre projet était
d'échanger d'abord avec les élèves
français et de chercher des
améliorations pour la protection de
l'environnement dans nos villes jumelées
les objectifs de notre projet c'est
surtout la protection de l'environnement
comme déjà dit
mais aussi d'avoir cet échange culturel
avec la france pour qu'on se complètent
mutuellement et pour concède
quelles sont les activités que vous avez
réalisé dans le cadre du projet et
demain vers vite d'aircal
nous nous sommes retrouvés souvent à
l'hôtel de ville plusieurs élèves de
plusieurs écoles de aschaffenburg
focaliser sur notre ville nous nous
sommes intéressés à la protection de
l'environnement
nous avons d'abord mené et enregistrer
des interviews avec d'autres jeunes
ensuite nous avons rencontré des experts
des différents domaines avec qui nous
avons parlé de la protection
environnementale aschaffenburg
nous avions également des séances en
ligne avec les élèves en échange concept
nous avons par exemple échanger avec les
élèves français sur nos intentions et
sur leurs intentions
nous avons parlé au maire
d'aschaffenburg et nous avons discuté
avec lui de quelques propositions
d'amélioration
qu'est ce que vous en retenez
[Musique]
je retiens que à l'avenir nous devons
prendre soin de l'environnement
et que nous ne pouvons pas attendre
d'avoir une solution parfaite devant
agir tout de suite
je garderai cette expérience en tête et
je pense qu'on va faire beaucoup de
petits changements dans la ville pour
améliorer la protection environnementale
l'échangé culturel est très important et
ensemble avec d'autres pays nous pouvons
mieux et nous engager pour la protection
environnementale
zone europe avec le soutien du fonds
citoyen franco allemand
c'est tout
[Musique]
à
l'eau froide enlever
qu'antoine and while they know my radio
clan devrait aussi nous sommes
aujourd'hui à radio que jane brain
aschaffenburg avec kerstin dinther
bonjour vous êtes pédagogue vous faites
partie de la direction pédagogique est
ce que vous pouvez a présenté la radio
avec plaisir radio claude brêthes est un
projet pédagogique médiatique ici achats
faits une bourre cela veut dire que nous
sommes à disposition des jeunes nous
voulons leur montrer comment on crée des
médias soit même au lieu de seulement
les consommer l'aspect le plus important
est de donner la voix aux jeunes pour
les sujets qui leur tiennent à coeur je
profite là quels profils sont les jeunes
qui viennent ici
c'est très différent bettman nous avons
de très jeunes participants comme les
élèves de 12 13 ans mais il ya aussi des
étudiants qui font déjà des études
certain journalisme il y à une grande
variété
10 radio and roll ou 10 miles ou d'image
non jung eun sun est ce que cette radio
head les jeunes à exprimer leur avis
elle leur donne vie la possibilité
parler de l'actualité
actuelle actu et le nice sochaux
pression
tout à fait car le programme est créé
par les enfants et les adolescents je
suis la personne qui leur indique les
conditions de base et les enfants et les
adolescents choisissent les sujets nous
allons aborder tous les sujets qu'ils
considèrent comme important ça peut être
de petits sujets comme par exemple les
années 80 que nous allons présenter la
semaine prochaine ce soir le sujet et
l'afghanistan vous voyez la diversité
des thèmes est déterminé par les jeunes
eux-mêmes welt qui choisit la
programmation musicale
les enfants et les adolescents également
ils définissent la sélection musicale
nous l'avons dit nous ne sommes pas une
radio grand public nous ne jouons pas de
la musique commerciale qui met tout le
reste et bien on le joue
welche sorte qu'elle sorte de musique
par exemple sont beispiel tascan on met
du heavy metal
de la musique d'auteur compositeur
interprète cannes c'est parfois aussi de
la musique classique nous tenons à
soutenir les artistes locaux c'est ce
vestige les artistes locaux c'est
important
il ya 100 % une fois par semaine nous
menons des interviews avec des artistes
locaux et ainsi ils présentent leur
programme et leur offre à dos 26 aïn
zinc à irène favorite si vous deviez
choisir et présenter un chanteur votre
préférée aux auditeurs de radio
sensations sations et aux
téléspectateurs de tv 60,18 ce serait
sous chalamont fun tv 60,18 forte
sustain
je vous dirais de demander aux jeunes
qui seront dans le studio tout à l'heure
car ils sont les experts j'ai des
préférences mais je suis vieille donc
c'est aux jeunes de décider merci donc
on se dirige maintenant dans le studio
de la radio où nous attendent pauline
ester elles sont toutes les deux
bénévoles de radio claude brêthes on se
retrouve tout de suite avec elle à lons
jour
bonjour à l'eau warum pourquoi
faites-vous partie de radio-canada
lambrette
j'aime les médias et traiter des sujets
de manière journalistique
azoïques pénaltouche qui change c'est
grâce à l'école que je suis impliqué
dans la radio la plupart du temps je
vois mes amis ici
à ce que
kerstin casting m'a dit que vous étiez
les meilleures personnes pour choisir un
chanteur ou une chanteuse locale à nous
présenter alors ce serait qui ein local
zinc a rason vie
je peux recommander à neil falcou j'aime
bien leur musique
aux palmiers j'aime tous les chanteurs
régionaux car ils sont tous bons je n'ai
pas de favori
danke schön merci vounet 26 10 radio
clank bret ndaq et pour découvrir radio
colombe est nous n'hésitez pas
été le site web clan bref point compte
des ja tinqueux merci beaucoup
zone europe
[Musique]
bonjour christine à creysse bonjour vous
êtes professeur de français au lycée
kronberg à aschaffenburg alors tout
d'abord qu'est ce qui pousse les jeunes
allemands à apprendre le français
d'accord alors moi je dirais qu ici à
l'école il ya plusieurs élèves qui ont
choisi le français parce qu'ils ont déjà
été en france pendant les vacances mais
il y a 6 dans cette région aussi
beaucoup de familles avec
bain des amis de famille en france alors
je dirais que ce sont les relations
humaines qui font aussi
glissant un motif pour apprendre le
français et comment est ce que vous vous
pouvez les motiver à apprendre le
français ce que vous pensez que c'est
important les jeunes allemands
d'apprendre le français est super
important parce que la france est un
partenaire
d'allemagne et ben
comprendre nos voisins c'est important
pour avoir les liant les relations entre
les générations qui suivent alors
comment est ce qu'on apprend le français
ici en allemagne est ce qu'on s'appuie
sur des textes qu'on regarde des films
est ce que on lit des textes d'auteurs
connus plus ou plus ou moins des deux
auteurs français ben oui alors je dirais
normalement on a des livres peints des
livres d'école alors on s'appuie bien
sûr des textes même les dernières années
beaucoup
beaucoup c'est évoluer non et ça veut
dire on s'appuie aussi des films en
chantant des chansons il y à des vidéos
des petits clips qu'on peut ajouter
aujourd'hui d'en peindre dans les
courses vous trouvez qu'il ya eu une
évolution dans l'apprentissage du
français par rapport à il ya quelques
années est ce que c'est plus attractif
d'apprendre maintenant le français qu'il
ya quelques années alors comme moi je
suis jeune prof je dirais que oui il y
avait eu une évolution parce que comme
moi j'étais
élève à l'école c'était plutôt les
textes il il faut traduire et tout ça et
aujourd'hui c'est plus libre alors on
parle beaucoup il y a des chansons comme
j'ai déjà dit et bien les élèves en veut
vraiment les faire parler le français
alors ça a vraiment changé et avec
toutes les possibilités techniques qu'on
a aujourd'hui alors je dirais qu'il y a
une grande évolution et c'est quoi les
difficultés que rencontrent les élèves
allemands pour apprendre le français par
exemple al'inverse on sait que les
français ont du mal par exemple avec les
déclinaisons en allemand bah oui alors
pour les jeunes talents je dirais que la
prononciation est super difficile et
aussi la les différences entre
l'orthographe et la prononciation
c'était super important à savoir mais
quand même difficile à apprendre et
aussi les conjugaisons en français c'est
pas assez facile pour les pour les
élèves allemands et si si vous deviez
décrire un peu les profils des élèves
que vous avez c'est d'époque des élèves
qui sont tous très heureux de venir en
cours de français où elle en a qui bat
il y en a aussi quelques uns qui n'aime
pas trop le français mais c'est clair
alors je trouve où je pense que tous les
élèves en ont des profils individuels
ainsi alors
par tout le monde aime le français c'est
ça alors vous le disiez à la france et
l'allemagne ont une histoire en commun
c'est sympa et toujours pas toujours été
très très joyeux est ce que c'est
important d'apprendre la langue du pays
voisins pour renforcer les liens entre
entre les deux pays ah oui tout à fait
alors je trouve que c'est super
important pour garantir garantir le
partenariat entre les deux pays alors
c'est pas seulement l'économie ou la
politique mais ce sont les jeunes et les
générations qui suivent qui font cette
amitié alors je suis un je trouve super
important quand apprennent le français
et pour pour terminer on vous disiez la
france est donc la france et l'allemagne
ont des relations très très lié pour
vous c'est quoi la relation
franco-allemande si vous deviez la
décrire alors pour moi c'est cessant les
gens alors c'est sans fin les personnes
la famille les amis alors ben la france
et l'allemagne s'est pas passé comme une
petite famille je dirais alors si on a
des copains des amis en france alors on
veut bien les garder et comme ça je
dirais c'est important de parler la
langue parce que parler une langue ce
n'est pas seulement les mots ou les
phrases c'est comme apprendre une autre
culture merci beaucoup si la grèce
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
français au lycée kronberg aschaffenburg
merci zone europe avec le soutien du
fonds citoyen franco allemand
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
10 gratuit
[Musique]
voilà
m
[Musique]
alors le programme erasmus fête cette
année ses 35 ans il n'est pas uniquement
réservé aux étudiants nous sommes avec
helmut maya vous travaillez à la mairie
d'aschaffenburg bonjour bonjour alors je
le disais le programme erasmus n'est pas
réservé aux étudiants vous avez vous
même pu profiter de ce programme est ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer le but de
la mobilité que vous avez effectué
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez été à la
mairie de saint germain en laye oui il y
a trois ans quand nous avons fait ce
stage et c'était avec une
caméra qui se travaille c'est elle
s'appelle sabine et il nous avons fait
ce stage ou à l'hôtel de ville et pour
faire des connaissances avec les
camarades de sagem en relais et pour
profiter qu un homme au travail à la
mairie et ça vous a appris beaucoup de
choses oui nous avons fait beaucoup de
visites par exemple c'était pour eux
c'était une usine contre le tfg a sali
par exemple est aussi au programme pour
de l'eau
potable c'était un programme
approché très très très cher parce que
au
protelos de l'hiver pour eux oui
la rendre potable exactement et est-ce
que vous conseilleriez à quelqu'un qui
hésite encore peut-être à faire une
mobilité en erasmus de le faire ce que
vous pensez que c'est une bonne chose
mais perçu c'est une bonne chose parce
que comme ge energy j'ai fait des
contacts plusieurs contacts avec les
camarades de chargement et il faut
profiter de la situation en france par
exemple parce que c'est quelque chose
différente peut-être et pour surtout
pour les policiers c'est très bien pour
faire des
progrès comme ça très bien alors je le
disais un saint germain aschaffenburg
celle trajet que vous avez effectué ces
ces deux villes sont jumelées également
depuis 1975 alors première question
comment est-ce qu'on peut renforcer les
liens entre ces deux villes peut-être
des activités chez que
vous avez un projet en cours autour du
cyclisme par exemple oui il est proche
on a beau faire on va faire approchait
de cyclisme avec les cyclotouristes ça
je m'en aller c'est prévu il ya déjà
deux ans malheureusement il avait des
problèmes avec coït mais on est sûr que
ça marche cette année et peut-être
revers rencontrera m c'est à dire les
camarades sagem allez vous prendre les
vélos pour aller à m et nous nous allons
prendre un autre nom mélo au vélo pour
aller à mettre aussi pour se
reconstruire et de plus il faut ajouter
pour faire des contacts parce que ici on
est aussi responsable policier me lâche
pour tous les to les écoles et tous les
élèves
on peut dire c'est très nécessaire pour
faire des échanges très bien justement
ces échanges sont incontournables dans
l'amitié franco allemande est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner votre définition
de l'amitié franco-allemande c'est quoi
l'amitié franco allemand entre huy
moi par exemple je suis né en 1963 c'est
exactement le tact qu'en a fait le
contrat entre h l'allemagne et la france
entre entre antennes relais et de gaulle
et c'est aussi le tact le 22 janvier
poserait faut se souvenir à the date et
c'est très très nécessaire parce que
l'amitié franco allemande nous sommes
deux pays directement à côté et c'est
traîner ce dossier très bien merci
beaucoup hellmuth manière d'avoir été
avec nous et si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur le programme erasmus il existe
un site internet info point rasmussen
pluzz.fr
zone europe
je ne peux pas penser à la
[Musique]
heine
j'allumais
[Musique]
faire
à
[Musique]
zone europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui n'oubliez pas vous pouvez
réagir et commenter cette émission sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag jf à
2022 merci aux fonds citoyen franco
allemand pour son soutien vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en podcast
audio et vidéo sur notre site et notre
application radio sensations on se donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine très
bonne soirée
sonne robe sûr sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile-de-france
zone europe avec le soutien du fonds
citoyen franco allemand